hello everyone welcome back to the 2019
Riga feeder Grand Prix is Schaffner
mamedyarov vs. Maxime for sure grab this
is a game one of the classics and it is
the final round obviously as this is the
finals
so it's a really interesting game we're
gonna really enjoy checking it out well
I hope but before we check out the game
I would just like to mention that a
further update has been made on the
argument of chess clock so now it is
fully released it is no longer in beta
so if you were one of the beta testers
you are welcome to leave the beta as now
you will be able to give a rating you
will be able to write a comment in the
google play store and you know if you
feel like it if you enjoyed the clock
and everything that has been updated as
a lot we have really sent a lot of
emails on what to improve you know just
if you feel like it leave a comment
leave a you know a rating three stars
four stars five stars whatever whatever
you feel the ad app were you know
deserves and well that's it that's what
I wanted to say and you know all in all
just update your chess clock and getting
back to this game before we check out
the actual game we do have some nice
photo so here it is all the photos are
compliments of Nicki Arriba official
photographer of the feeder Grand Prix
there we have it first move being made
by this gentleman here also a bonus
question who amongst you can identify
the gentleman you know feel free to you
know enlighten everyone in the comments
and also here we have a very nice photo
of Maxime he doesn't like that the d4
pawn isn't perfectly centered so he's
gonna you know just fix that and he's
not sorry about it either so let's just
check it out Mahmoud Arif opens with d4
like you've just you know seen on the
photo night we have six we have c4 g6
and Knight to c3 and d5 well naughty but
the d5 and we have the groom for defense
so if you remember we covered the game
not so long ago in the Grantchester or
Zagreb edition that has been played well
not all that long ago maxime tried the
groom full defense against Magnus
Carlsen but Magnus Carlsen really
unleashed his bishops pair from hell and
in the end he was able to prevail
so here obviously Maxime doesn't mind
that he lost the game with his roomful
defense against the world champion as
like I said alongside Peter Svidler
Maxie Marshall de Gras is considered one
of the greatest you know players of the
groom for today so we have seen after
some d5 Knight captures on d5 and now
efore we have Knight captures and c3b
captures Bishop to g7 and here
Magnus said Knight to f3 on the board
when when he played against Maxime in
Zagreb but here mama D ro goes for Queen
to a4 check we have Queen to d7 blocking
check hoping to trade Queens but
mamedyarov isn't interested with Bishop
to e3 and now this is a very nice idea
where mommy TR has plans of developing
this Bishop over to f4 bringing the roof
to c1 and then putting pressure on the C
file but you will see what happens with
b6 by Max in preparing to fin get to the
light square Bishop with Knight to f3
now finally the ship to b7 and now just
Bishop to d3 defending d4 pawn and here
mama already had this position against
the box Sebastian Bulgarian Bundesliga
2015 where Maxime played upon the c5 but
here we have castles by Maxine we have
castles by Mahmud Arif and only now c5
so here the game again transposes into
this game we already mentioned that
Maxime played against borgnar in 2015
and there well they're a different move
was played rook to d1 was played there
but also some of the moves that are
familiar in this position our Bishop to
e3 and Bishop to g5 but the movement
idea of plate brush of the f4 is a new
move so it is as a move 12 that we have
a completely new game as this move has
never been played before so how do you
deal with this well you want to start
developing the bishop and the Queen
control the a6 squares you can't really
develop the knight via the a6 square so
you have to try and defend
develop at the vs c6 although it's very
hard if you just develop it now d5 will
be very annoying here for black so here
Maxime further decided to trade
with capture son before capture son
before end only now Knight to c6 but
it's not a problem
d5 same as in the game against the
Magnus and now this Knight comes to a5
and in the game against Magnus if you
remember in Zagreb this night remained
there for the rest of the game at the
end of the game the night played few
more moves and that was it so let's see
how the knight will fare this game rook
the c1 like we said this is the idea the
bishop on f4 now controls the c7 square
mami taro wants Luke to c7 so of course
the magazine has to prevent this with
rook F to c8 and now h3 making some
breathing room for the King with East 6
challenging white strong center and now
of course as the Queen and Bishop are
guarding the d6 square it is only
natural that we will push d6 here so on
the next move white of course wants to
push a 5 if black allows this then it's
just gonna be a slow painful death
so maxime plays f6 he wants to prevent
it but mama DRF says nope you you
haven't really prevented anything he
just pushes a5 and here if you capture
for example captures and Knight captures
with an attack on the Queen now if you
move the Queen then even even d7 is
coming so here if you capture you get
Bishop captures and here with this pawn
here rook to c7 is again a threat and
with white having the bishop pair it
will just be again a very very slow and
painful death for for black so your
other option is to play f5 but then your
Bishop is just lame there on g7 it's you
know it's supposed to be a dragon and
here it's not even a lizard and well
White has a beautiful central pawn chain
here rook to c7 will again be threatened
at some point you'll probably double
just double double rooks on the C file
and that's pretty much it so here after
E 5 Maxine did the only thing he had
left he played Bishop captures on f3 and
now of course if you capture you no
longer have control over over d5 square
black will be able to capture here so
here he captures on f6
with Bishop captures on f6 and now G
captures on f3 and now again
rook to c7 is a threat the bishop still
controlling the c7 squares
here my media of sorry MVL pushes ePHI
he wants you know the bishop to get out
of here with russia back to d2 and now
again how do you play this it's a very
passive position to play probably what
you want to do is just play something
like King 2h8 and then after well white
defends the h3 pawn
then try to bring the knight back into
the game but now you're gonna go Bishop
the a6 kick away the rope from the C
file rook to d8 and now Bishop back to
b5 and now you have a lot of pressure
here on this night you're gonna play
rook see - you're gonna bring the other
rock over to c1 and it's just gonna be a
very tough game for black to play but
this was probably the best course of
action for Maxine Maxine went rook
captures on c1 first he wanted to trade
all of the rooks but this doesn't really
work in his favor
rook address on C 1 we have rook to c8
and now mama Daryl just trades once
again with rook captures Queen captures
and now he plays King to g2 he wants to
defend his h3 pawn but also possible was
just bishop the e4 because the threat of
Bishop to b5 check prevents you from
capturing here if you captured an Bishop
b5 check King g7 and Queen to c3 just
wins the game because the bishop of
control v h6 square this bishop slices
all the way here
Queen to c7 check is coming and this
King is getting checkmated so there
wasn't really a need to defend this h3
pawn here but you know better safe than
sorry
and it's not like black has any active
ideas in the position so King to g2 by
mama D RF and now Bishop back to d8 the
queen is now coming over to e6 and well
black will just have to try and hold
this passed pawn here and somehow at
some point bring get this knight into
the game with bush up the e4 of course
preparing Bishop to b5 check and here
black one tweenty 6 as expected so feel
free to pause the video here and try to
find well believe it or not a winning
move for white in this position I'll
give you a couple of seconds for those
of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an
excellent threatener of winning the
blacks black queen and for those of you
who just wanna enjoy a show Queen to d3
is the the strongest idea here f4 was
also nice but queen d3 just forces
matters now Bishop to d5 is the the real
threat
so here maxime went King to g7 and just
Bishop to c3 by mommy the heir of the
thread is f4 now as the pond will not be
able to capture so you're just gonna
have an awesome pawn chain once again
here Queen to f6 was played by Maxine
just you know preparing to meet f4 with
Queen captures on f4 but here
mama Yara played the classiest move
possible he played King to f1 and here
maxime Varsha holograph resigned the
game unmoved 28 in classical time former
which is really insane as up until this
point
maxime beaugeois graphic that one in the
Phaedo grand prix in the classical time
format so I don't think the rapids were
even reached and here it's like Maxime
doesn't want to leave the in the
classical time format he loses in 28
moves which is really insane here mama
Dee I've created a beautiful toots Wong
for example if you try to find a move
for black you're gonna have a very hard
time doing so because the knight can't
move all of the squares that the knight
can use are covered by the Queen the
pawn and this bush appear slicing all
the way here you can't really move the
dark square Bishop the pawn controls all
of these squares if you move the Queen
then f4 is definitely coming so what can
you do you could try something like King
to f7 just try and get the King out of
this ugly diagonal but it doesn't help
still f4 and now after twin captors and
f4 you get Queen to d5 check King to f8
and now push up the b2 preparing for
Bishop to h8 check and after Queen to f7
brush up to h8 check King to g8 but now
just Queen to a8 there are too many
threats here Queen captures here is a
threat Bishop d5 is a threat winning the
Queen so after Queen eh were just gonna
play check you have to go all the way to
a trait and now Bishop g5 I just wins
you know this types of material and the
game on the other hand after this King
to f1 move you could try something like
h5 just you know make a move but still
after Queen
five all of the same ideas are happening
now membership captures on e5 is a
threat you can't prevent this and again
it will be just you know the blacks
position will deteriorate by itself
another thing after King f1 well you
could try Queen to h4 to maybe create
some threats here with Queen captures on
h3 how but it doesn't work just Bishop
captures on e5 check King to h6 and now
f4 the Queen guards the h3 phone and you
know everything will just continue
falling apart for black
so of course maxime notice after King to
f1 what a beautiful way to to end the
game might even use this as a thumbnail
I don't know probably I probably will so
yeah really really an impressive showing
but Mammadov and it seems that although
Maxine is the world's leading player in
the groom fold now it doesn't seem that
it actually works against top players
because the bishop pair is just too
strong and this night like we said
against Magnus it played a move or two
at the end of the game but here it
remained on a5 so I don't know if it's a
really passive way to play the groom
fold but it seems the top players I have
found a way to refute the groom for at
least for now sure that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it like I said don't
forget to update your I got massive
chess clock I would like to thank Jarrod
Weiss Thomas pander Troy here in crispy
card and Tony Moore what guitar for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos so
you're thinking for watching and I will
see soon
continuing the coverage of the Fida
Grand Prix finals continuing the
Capablanca saga and the usual checking
up in your suggestions thank y'all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day